if you want to achieve anything amazing
in your life I can tell you right now
you've got to break your bad habits if
you want to achieve something incredible
step number one is to understand that
the way that you break your bad habits
is by letting them atrophy so you don't
spend a lot of time thinking about the
bad habit and how we're going to break
it you have to find something new that
you're going to put your time and
attention into now there is a bit of
both though so it's going to go like
this step number one you're going to
pattern interrupt you go to do that
negative thing you call it out
immediately you stop yourself in the
middle of it if you let's say that you
want to get in shape and your bad habit
is midnight snacking and you're so used
to doing it that you sleep walk out of
bed you open that fridge and you start
cramming things into your face and you
get four bites into stuffing your mouth
most people go up it's already shot it's
already wasted it's done I might as well
finish the thing not anymore that
doesn't make any sense whatsoever at the
moment that you realize you're doing the
thing that you said you weren't going to
do you're going to pattern interrupt I
don't do midnight snacking spit out what
you have left throw away what's in your
hand close the refrigerator door swish
your mouth out spit back in the sink
brush your teeth do whatever you have to
do to remind yourself that in fact you
don't do that thing anymore hey it's
Evan Carmichael and I make these videos
because in my first business I struggle
to believe in myself I quit on my
business partner and the thing that
saved me was watching the successful
stories of entrepreneurs they gave me
the inspiration to keep going as well as
the strategies of what to do and quite
honestly I still need their stories and
motivation today as well so today let's
live your best believe life and learn
how to reclaim your life and live your
dreams enjoy
the new thing is you've got to have a
new habit developed to develop a habit
you've got to identify something that
you want
the whole point to building a habit is
that it's going to get you somewhere
that you want to go if you don't want to
go somewhere badly enough you will not
have the energy that you need to see it
through when you go to the fridge and it
tastes so good when you're eating
the thought of having six-pack abs or
the thought of holding your kid as they
grow up the thought of being able to
walk your daughter down the aisle
whatever it is that's motivating you to
want to get in shape in that moment it's
got to show up and it's got to show up
big so the way that we break the bad
habits the way that we let them atrophy
is we get so excited about this new
thing that we're putting all of our time
and attention into that suddenly that
other thing begins to fall away because
it is the enemy of what we want and we
actually want this thing that's why you
can't pick [ __ ] you've got to pick
something that you actually care about
this has got to be something that you
really want now
if your secret question is
Tom how do I build a habit
when I don't know what I want
then the answer is very different then
the answer is you have to find something
that you want and build desire around it
rule number two is have discipline with
Brendan burchard I'll give you three
principles yeah or greater discipline
and then I'll tell you the actual three
things to do to generate more discipline
in such a way
that your personal growth grows that you
feel like alive and connected and
meaningful and joyous on this journey
because that's what really matters I
mean discipline sucks unless in some
ways the outcome is progress greater
engagement and aliveness of life and
greater success in whatever way you
measure that so the three principles of
all of like discipline comes down to
number one mastering your schedule I
know that sounds so boring but it's so
absolutely fundamental to your focus to
your progress to your health to
everything it doesn't matter if you say
okay I only once I only want to schedule
one thing today that's fine with me I'm
not trying to own every hour of your
life but that one thing better be
awesome and it better be a needle mover
so scheduling show up when it's
scheduled and then the third thing which
is most important as a principal or all
of discipline no discipline happens
unless on a real consistent basis unless
you have social connection
all of the research shows the most
productive people the most focused
people the people who are most fulfilled
in doing meaningful work have attached a
meaning that their focus intention their
hard work
is attached to social connection meaning
I'm going to show up for this because
it's going to make me a better mom or
parent I'm going to get healthy so I
have more energy for the kids I am going
to do this project so my team and
Company grows so we serve more people
and we make an impact it's like the hard
work must be attached to impact but the
impact isn't just so self like oh I'll
get this it has to have a social
connection like you you have to have a
reason to show up over and over and over
for others that's why we always teach in
high performance you have to have a
little card that says who needs me on my
a game today yeah I am disciplined
because I I wouldn't be less disciplined
doing a Morning Show I'm more
disciplined to do a Morning Show because
Jamie's there she's waiting on the other
end if I don't get there I feel like a
chump
so that's important you know there's
three principles right
schedule it show up attach social
connection
but now here's the things I would do if
you said Britain if you could only be
disciplined about three things what
would you do and it's not what you all
think
it's totally not what you all think and
this is very much
that makes me happy and progress in life
so they're not sexy the number one thing
if I could give anyone a discipline to
always do on the first of every single
month you do a whole life review
when that calendar hits one as in the
first of the month
you look at every major area of your
life you score yourself you ask how
you'd like to improve that and what
could you do this month
because most people never improve their
life because they never face their life
yeah you have to look at it so every
first of the month that's why that's
that's for those who are new to us
growth day began growth they actually
began because I said let's do it let's
do our personal development on the first
of the month so I go live for two hours
and growth day uh so if you're not a
member go to growthday.com because I do
a full personal development seminar on
the first of every single month because
I feel like if we start the month off we
nail that we start it with good attitude
energy but also you're looking into the
month and asking is the way I've
scheduled this month
going to help me move towards the
lifestyle I want or the accomplishment
of the major three projects I'm working
on in my life
and also if we don't do this I feel
how many people can relate to this where
if you don't do this all of a sudden you
blink and you're like oh it's halfway
through the month or oh three months
have gone by
I don't even know what's how did this
even happen right how many times have we
done that like wait a minute it's it's
Thanksgiving like wait a minute it's
spring break and it's like your life
flies by
um in a blur this is the for those who
have the high performance planner you
know this page super well this is your
monthly review section in the high
performance planner and what it does is
it makes you look at the 10 major areas
of your life from Health to mental
emotional partner or love Family Friends
mission experiences Spirit finances
learning growth it helps you reflect on
the things you learned in the last month
learn about others learn about yourself
what you're grateful for the main
priorities coming up the decisions you
needed to make or could make of your
your monthly review and orienting
yourself to your your goals and three
year goals like if I don't do that on
the first of the month what happens is
the middle of the month I don't what am
I doing I might be showing up and I'm
showing up in a hot mess all the time
because I don't have
Direction yeah so if I could give you
anything start the first of the month
super clear about that month if if
that's all you did I promise you'd be
more engaged with your life second thing
I do I I believe another review is
needed every Sunday
so Sunday do your weekly review and your
weekly planning I don't care if it takes
10 minutes an hour I think it's
important to go okay on Sunday is this
upcoming week am I clear about what I
want of that am I clear about how I can
serve am I clear about these little
Slots of time do they make sense to me I
mean just that it can take so fast so
third thing yeah all right listen if I
could give you three things to move the
needle in your life number one is a
month or on the first of the month look
out and most please don't think that
this or the Sunday review which is the
second point is just about your schedule
you are reviewing the major parts of
your life you're connecting with them
you're scoring them you're asking what
more you desire there and what's
something simple you can do to improve
that area of your life each month it
doesn't have to be huge life
transformation because look
transformation takes time you might be
like little this little thing this is a
little this thing but being aware of it
that's important so the monthly
then the Sunday
and then you have I just I don't know
everyone's already wrote this in their
things and they just know it to be true
you gotta win your mornings again and
bring intention
for I think two things every day if we
can bring intention for two things every
day we win that day to me the first one
is I'm going to bring the joy to this
day I'm going to choose my attitude I'm
gonna I'm gonna develop a mindset that
is unshakable that is joyful that is I'm
going to be in every room
I it doesn't matter if I'm the loudest
I'm going to be try to be the most
generous and grateful person in that
room I'm just going to bring good energy
be responsible for the energy you are
projecting on to others and into this
world so I think for me that intention
of I have an intention to have joy each
day I'm gonna have some fun I'm gonna
I'm gonna make that happen because
sometimes life doesn't do it for you
yeah they just hasn't so I'm gonna bring
the joy so that's my but that's an
intention so what I'm saying is the
third discipline is every day you have
intentions
for feeling life yeah for me feeling
life means bring the joy
that's number one I'm going to bring the
joy and number two I'm going to make a
moment with somebody today
maybe I send them an audio maybe it's
the way I look at my wife maybe it's the
thing I call up my mom and or I sense a
beautiful appreciation email or text to
somebody
but every day I'm going to bring the joy
into the day and I'm going to make a
moment because at the end of your life I
learned this to face my death twice in
my life
you remember these moments and scenes
with other people
it's so important to realize that
and so you have to ask are you going to
have enough of those moments in scenes
are they going to be at the end of your
life you kind of if it's true if it's
true you see a movie
what are the scenes of that movie gonna
be
you get to direct that and I promise the
scenes in the movie almost always have
these beautiful connections with others
it's like most people don't realize the
ending movie of their life
is love scenes and connection scenes
with other people where like these like
meaningful moments if you will let's
just call a meaningful moments that's
what you see at the end meaningful
moments so if if that is true
if it's true then you have to purposely
structure and build in meaningful
moments so you love the movie at the end
you know that you love the movie you
want to watch the movie again that you
appreciate that you're gonna bust out
the good wine and have that good
with that meaningful movie and so every
day that's now that's mine I'm gonna
bring joy to this day and I'm gonna make
moments yeah that's so good you might
have different intentions maybe your
intention's like I'm gonna do this thing
as a mom or as a leader or as a whatever
doesn't matter to me but if you don't
have the intention the days just plays
by nothing you can be working hard you
can show you can get your schedule down
you can have your your calendar
prioritized with all the tabs and all
the different marker colors and
everything else but if there's no
intention for feeling
you just you were a good robot today yep
but you didn't we all had days like that
where we feel like a human doing right
Not a Human Being that's so good Brendan
that's so good and and a moment a
meaningful moment can be different for
every single person but how many days
did we go through and we forget and a
meaningful moment's free you know what I
mean it's like how many days do we
forget to do that that's so powerful I
love that I love that you have so to me
that's funny that the discipline is to
have the intention
right yeah rule number three is do the
work with Eric Thomas actually getting
serious about your life requires some
work other than just being moved
emotionally what does some of that work
listen to me I think the first thing and
maybe Steven called me I don't know I
think that who said it come come out the
window and get in the mirror
and I think too many of us are in the
window meaning you're looking at
everybody else and what everybody else
is doing and you don't know what you
want because you know so well what they
want you you feel me like I there's
certain things I don't want I want a
relationship with Ed I want that I don't
necessarily want some of the like I
don't wear watches I'm not against
watches I don't think there's anything
wrong with a watch yeah I don't think
it's just not my thing I don't as a
matter of fact if you ever watch me I
don't even like to wear a belt like I
got this phobia anything that's on my
body I wish I could like have a uh the
emperor the naked Emperor like I wish I
had his suit you know I said like I hate
putting on clothes you feel me I hate it
but
I know that there are people who are
constantly watching what other people
are doing and now you're wanting what
they want when you don't even want that
and the way I started this whole uou
video uh in New Zealand was I don't I
was with a group of people and I promise
you they ticked me off you know they
were like trying to you need to do this
and you need to do that and I started
the whole speech after having a
conversation with them saying I don't
want what you want
and you're not gonna make me want what I
don't want I don't want that I want I
love relationships I go to Ed crib and
chill we can drink water dog on it I
don't care we could just walk on the
beach as long as there's a relationship
and and it's making me better and it's
nurturing me and it's that is feeding
that human need for a sense of belonging
and safety and self-actualization I'm
not really on nothing else and so you
know for my birthday what you want to do
eat I just want to be in the room by
myself because I'm always with people or
helping people I just want to chill and
so I know what I want and because I know
what I want I'm not going to do what you
want me to do and fail well gotta hear
what I'm saying please when you don't
look in the mirror you are not empowered
when you look in the mirror you see you
and what you want and what you need to
do and what you need to be when you look
in the mirror you reflect when you
reflect you transform when you transform
you change when you change you do things
differently when you do things
differently you get different outcomes
when you're looking in the window and
you staring at other people there is no
reflection it's only comparing and as
long as you compare yourself to another
model I drive an Escalade I'm from
Detroit I drive a s plan a Cadillac
right when I see a dude in a Bentley I'm
looking at that big like fire but at no
point am I going I want to trade my
Cadillac in for the Bentley I've seen
some fire land I moved to Cali everybody
got a Range Rover I see some fire Range
Rover I've seen some Lamborghini I
looked at these vehicles and go my what
craftsmanship I've never gone I feel
just escalate I feel so bad I'm in an
Escalade this is the car that was my
dream car the black on black this is
what I dreamed of this is it this is my
dream vehicle and so I don't look at
what others have and compare I actually
look at what others have I actually look
at Ed and go man there's a god wow look
how he operation is gift and his
anointing look at his energy and his
passion look at his delivery and then I
go hey God where's mine
why did you give me and and out not give
me ads I don't want ads why I can't do
ads like hey I can do ads but I can do
Eric's like air can do air so I'm saying
get out of the window get in the mirror
look at you study you figure out you I
my boy Mustafa said something the other
day that was deep moose said when you
don't know what to work on work on
yourself
wow when you don't know what to work on
work on yourself and I want to add to
that when you do know what you want work
on yourself because it is the working of
yourself and the improving and getting
better Ed been on this Earth he'd been
on this Earth I've been on this Earth
I wasn't ready to meet Ed
when I was the dude eating out of trash
cans of victim I would not have taken
advantage of that relationship I it
wasn't until I got older that the
Creator said are you ready you ready for
these type of you ready for these type
of relationships now you're ready why
because you are who you need to be I
heard the coach McVeigh I think is his
name and he gonna kill me if that's not
his name the coach for uh the Rams he'll
kill me if that ain't his name right he
said um yeah and forgive me uh uh
forgive me but he said
yo we brought Eric here because he
shares our values you'd like he shares
our values and the stuff that we talk
about and what we're about he talks
about that stuff and so I didn't get to
go because I'm a great speaker it's a
lot of great speakers matter of fact he
said yo we don't bring a lot of people
in here but we felt Eric could move the
needle and we want to win another Super
Bowl and so for me it's like yo I wasn't
ready for you 20 30 years ago I'm so
glad God didn't give me the opportunity
but when he gave it to me because I
worked on myself I worked on becoming a
better man for me not for Dede not for
Jalen not for J not for my mother for me
I became a better man because when I
looked in the word I realized I wasn't
living up to my potential and then by
doing the work I connect with another
man who's doing the work neither one of
us now it might be a little bit perfect
than I have but uh let me tell you
something not perfect but progressing
trying
fixing
revamping restructuring repurposing and
when you do those things y'all I
guarantee you
the way the brain works in the spirit
works when you start focusing on stuff
and you're willing to make the
adjustments it's gonna it's gonna come
to you eventually I promise you that
also to make sure you're actually taking
action after watching this video I
designed a special free worksheet just
for this video the worksheet will
highlight all of the Lessons Learned in
this video as well as pull out our three
favorite learnings and quotes that will
inspire you to actually do something the
worksheet will also give you space to
write down what your key takeaways are
and your specific plan of action to make
sure you're getting results if you want
the worksheet design specifically for
this video absolutely for free there's a
link in the description below go click
on it and start building the momentum in
your life and your business I'll see you
there rule number four is learn from
failures with Tony Robbins hard things
to ask like I don't want to ask you the
things you always get asked so I get
asked things and these are the ones that
I have struggled with
it's not is it okay to quit meaning is
there a point where
and and how do you know if I'm on a path
if it's just not working I'm in a
business that's just not working or I'm
in a relationship that's just not
working I think there's we've created
this culture that quitting is this
horrible thing if you ever quit that's
daily and I think some people create
this bondage around them almost in a
relationship or in in a business
environment where pivoting even is like
you know something a terrible thing to
do I'm just curious what you would what
you would say about that that's a great
quality question it reminds me of one
more thing that's changed within me
because you know I stayed in a
relationship for 20 years where I was
really not happy I made everybody else
happy which was my whole sacrifice there
and um and the reason I did it was
because I grew up with four fathers
right I swore I'd never get a divorce so
you know you build these ideals I
remember there's certain things like I'd
rather die than that oh what a stupidest
thing to say but we develop these
beliefs that once they become an ideal
they kind of have they possess you and
they take you over so so you got to be
able to question anything and so the
answer your question is yes there's a
time to move on there's a time to start
something new there's a time to learn
the lesson that this business or this
relationship or this experience has
given you and make a move because
otherwise the real testers are you
growing like if you're in a relationship
you know it's a great relationship if
you're constantly wanting to be better
for the person you love if you don't
really give a [ __ ] what they think
that's not a good sign right right I
mean it just means that there's not the
level of of intimacy there's not the
level of connection you might have been
together forever but it's not where it
needs to be so it's like get telling
yourself the truth I think is the
hardest thing for people and I think the
ideals get in the way of that truth
meaning the things you've you know and
grandized in your mind to be absolute
but I think when it comes to a business
it's not an easy question when it comes
to an investment I don't and Investments
it's easy I don't move to a new
investment until I found a better one I
don't just get pulled by the next shiny
thing I really look and make sure there
when it comes to businesses
I'm pretty crazy I've stayed in
businesses way too long I should have
probably gotten out but I did it and
then sold it and it made a little money
it was just it was my whole thing that I
don't quit so but I think there are
times when you have to adapt the
business to something new I mean if I
was still doing what I was doing two
years ago you know on the road doing
what I was doing I mean I would do 115
cities on average
um usually 12 to 16 countries I was on a
train playing a helicopter every two to
three days and I mean I don't mean and
no one would have ever stopped me
because they couldn't because there's so
much momentum of what I'm doing what
about doing that right now you know my
250 employees at that company would be
all unemployed you know because all
around the world it made it illegal to
do what I was doing so you have to be
able to tell yourself the truth about
where you are and also they'll not give
up too easily by saying where's the
season of this business okay whereas the
development like if a business is really
young it's a toddler business it's gonna
burn more cash then it's going to give
you back if it's a you know if it's a
business that's in that GoGo phase that
teenage phase you get overconfident
grows like crazy and then you don't have
the profits at some point when the sales
slow down and you got real trouble is it
a business that's aging but also I gotta
look at what's the industry like I'll
give an example I have a friend really
good guy maybe 44 45 years old Prime of
his life like you had really well put
together I mean takes care of his body
great mind great mindset without giving
his personal life away he owns a very
large business in Australia dominates an
industry and the industry relates to big
box office supplies okay so I had them
at one of my business seminars and I'm
walking him through these stages just
like a human being goes through life
stages so does a business just like
history right yes if you know what stage
you're in you know you can do the right
thing at the wrong time and you don't
get rewarded yes rant in the winter you
don't get rewarded right buy a house
sounds good 2007. maybe not the best
time right you know so it's like you got
to take a look at where these things fit
where is the where is the real decision
making here that makes this happen so
anyway he's got this off supply business
and he's young and dynamic so in his
life cycle he's in his prime
yeah his business is in its Pride he's
worked for years it's crushing it
but where's the industry is that a young
business a growing business yeah
an aging business and there's no
question it's an aging business and I
said to him I said you got to separate
these out because if you're using your
brain intelligently you got to sell this
business because even though you got a
great business the multiple is going to
go down every year because the
industry's going down yes you take those
resources and reinvest so again it's
looking at things by telling yourself
the truth seeing what stage they're in
and seeing what stage the world's in
because you might have the best idea in
the world but it's not going to work
when everybody's shed in their homes
perhaps depending about what the product
or service is so you have to adapt rule
number five is Follow Your Passion with
Dr Gabor mate after your 33 years in
medical practice
um you you described that you had a bit
of a you kind of tuned into a creative
cooling which was writing well I began
to relate when I was a physician so my
first book on ADHD after I was diagnosed
it was published in 1999 now so that was
23 years ago now so I began to write and
even before then I wrote Because I wrote
columns for newspapers
but yes there was a time in my life
where the writing impulse which had been
with me all my life was stifled and and
and and and stymied
and so was I because I had this
frustration in fact they had this sense
that there's something I needed to
express
but I didn't know what and they didn't
know how and at some point I realized oh
yeah I need to write so that began
before I finished medical practice but
it certainly
um
has been essential to my ongoing
unfolding as a human being
I was so compelled by that when I when I
read about that because um
I've started to really understand the
value of creativity in all of our Lives
regardless of whether we have the luxury
of being called an artist or not and so
what in your view is the importance of
well you're you're singing my tune here
if I may say it that way because
um I quote in this book uh there's a
great Hungarian Canadian stressed
researcher called Janos Shelley a
c-l-y-e and Celia is the one who
actually coined the word stress in the
sense that we use it today and he's the
one that showed in the laboratory how
stress diminishes the immune system and
this this organizes the hormones and and
ulcerates the stomach and all this kind
of stuff but
still you also said and they quote him
here what is in US must out what is in
us most out
that we all have to follow our key of
your urges in the way that nature
prepared for us otherwise we can be
hopeless hopelessly hemmed in by
frustration I'm paraphrasing him very
closely
so
BR created an image of God I mean as you
know what are your religious views are
but that sense that we created images of
God means that we are creators because
the essence of God is creation
in fact we call God the Creator and we
call the result of that creation
if we're greater than if we're if we're
offshoots of that creative dynamic in
the universe then it means that it's in
us to create and whatever form that
takes I mean you know you don't want to
see me
do art you know unless you
I can do a pretty good stick figure you
know but but I'm married to a nurse
um
so that crazy doesn't have to take the
form of formal art but it does it if it
takes some flow of something that's
inside you that needs to come out
otherwise as Celia says you get
hopelessly hemmed in by frustration and
so in that sense everybody's got that
creative urge and that may take the form
of social intercourse it might take the
form of gardening I don't care communion
with nature
athletic expression I don't care what
but but there's somebody everybody's got
it and if people don't realize they have
it it's only because life is HEM demand
and they're too busy and sometimes they
are trying to make a living or trying to
survive or too disconnected from
themselves but it's in all of us and to
the extent that we don't give it
expression we suffer
one of the things that really hems it in
is um
is the prospect that we might not be
good at it because we think to express
ourselves creatively we kind of join a
competition of sorts and that's that's a
trap we can fall into so if I'm gonna DJ
I need to become a good DJ yeah but in
Social comparison or else I don't want
to but what I've come to learn is in
fact the act of DJing alone in my
kitchen at midnight is is the reward
regardless of outcome or whether there's
a crowd there it's just me and my dog
listening that is the expression is the
reward not the achievement or the medal
that I might get although yeah not the
external well look I went through that
in the writing of this book so here I am
this you know
writer who writes about you know trauma
and you know healing and all of a sudden
I'm in a panic because I'm writing a
book and I realize that the problem was
that you talked about identifying with
your work so I'd identify with this book
so the problem wasn't the book
because let's say I write the book and
it's not a success I mean okay big
headline in the Sunday Times book not a
big success you know like how big a big
deal is that in the history of the
universe
but if I identify with the book
and it's not going well then if the book
fails then I'm feeling as a person which
then goes back to my very earliest uh
concern about not being worth it you
know so once I disidentified
I said no this is just a book it may be
a good book it may be an important book
maybe a book that doesn't hit the mark
but it's only a book and how it goes
says nothing about me or my worth
once I could decouple that then I could
confidently and much more comfortably go
back to the writing of it but I went to
that crisis it seems like a bit of a
paradox that this the lack of self-worth
would would motivate someone to to
create great things because they want
the approval but at the same time make
the process so agonizing because their
self-esteem seems to be on the line yeah
or their sense of self-worth is on the
line
well that Dynamic was in me once I
realized it I let go of it you know so
it didn't it didn't dominate me in the
end and uh honest to God by the time I
finished the book
I'm not just saying this in retrospect
it's it's the best seller now in several
countries but
I actually said to myself and I meant it
now I've done the book
that's what matters
I've said what was in me to say
how the world reacts
I can't control and it doesn't actually
matter it on a fundamental level it's
not that I don't want this book to be
excess I mean success of course I wanted
to sell 10 zillion copies but
that doesn't Define my self-worth or how
I function in the world how I feel about
myself honestly it does not and I I
understood that by the time I finished
working on it
so once it's done it's out there doing
its work or not doing its work
but I don't have to hang my own sense of
self on how the book does and rule
number six the last one before some very
special bonus Clips is work hard and
smart with Dean graziosi who am I when
no one's watching I don't want to say I
want to be the best man to my wife but
I'm doing crap on my phone when no one's
watching I don't want to say I'll be a
good dad and show a picture on Instagram
with me and my kids but not really
listening to them and spending more time
on my phone than being with them I don't
want to say that I want to create
Independence and and donate money and
build Family Security and leave a legacy
but I'm binging out on Netflix on the
weekend or drinking too much every time
I get sad just the default to that
rather than do it I want to be congruent
I want to make it so and I'm surely not
perfect at this but I want to make it
though if you had a hidden camera on me
for six months there'd only be a few
congruencies and that's success to me
and I'd love for you to think about that
this could be the beginning of a new you
a beginning of not playing small a
beginning of not feeling bad about what
you want out of life but there are key
principles that really
um if they're not a part of the
ingredients the Cake's never baked I
want to share a little bit uh just in
three minutes uh my back story and I
think it's important not because I want
you to know about me but I hope it
relates to you you know we all have the
thing that drives us you're all here for
a reason you're either running away from
something that's not so good something a
little painful right
or you want to run towards a bigger life
there's something in your life that's
uncomfortable and you want to move away
from that from that job from that
relationship you're in from being
dependent on someone else to show the
world you're the to be the woman that
God designed you to be or the man God
designed to be something just doesn't
align with you and you want to move away
from that thank you
or life's not bad things are okay but
you know you're meant for more you're
called to serve more be more do more
donate more right a hundred percent of
you are here for one of those one of the
other reasons and most of you here are
both you want to move away and then move
towards right we didn't have money as a
kid we all got our story not poor me
just this is my this is my story
um but what really was my muse my
motivation was my mom she worked three
jobs my parents split when I was three
dad's a good guy but he never helped us
financially and my mom worked as a hair
stylist and cleaned houses and painted
houses
three jobs to make nothing come home
nine o'clock every night always tired
and come home to our trailer right I
lived in the only trailer park in our
little town my sister and I watched my
mom work our tails off to where she got
arthritis at a young age and her back
always hurt so I just remember being 10
or 11 saying I'm just gonna get rich I
don't know how I'm gonna get rich and
take care of that woman who sacrificed
so much you know so we all need that
driver
so for me that was it so I started
cutting firewood at a young age I
started fixing wrecked cars and I got
into my first real estate deal then I
got a tow truck company I started
building houses I started doing all
these things and I started getting some
real good momentum in my mid-20s by the
time I was 30 I retired my mom retired
my dad I got to do some of these really
cool things
but around 27 years old something really
shifted my life I saw Tony Robbins on TV
in an infomercial and this big guy I
felt like he was talking directly to me
and it was something I had never done up
until that time in my life
I paid for information I know my Dad
saying to me are you nuts you paid for a
guy to talk to you he's like I'll talk
to you for free and I felt like saying
yeah but if I listen to you I'll get
married four times in divorce like you
are and always struggling financially I
love you Dad but but if I listen to you
I'll think I'll get what you have so I
kind of checked the Tony Robbins and I
won't go super long on it but it
fundamentally shifted me because I
hadn't read books up until that point I
had some success in my life I surely did
but I had it in a kind of a a hosed up
way anybody have a little ever have
success in your life but you know it's
not healthy right you're just moving
away from pain so much that doesn't feel
congruent is who you are
and I I devoured
what I bought from Tony I do I learned
that I could craft a new story that I
could have different beliefs that I
could use my past as my fuel I learned
that life happens for us not to us I
learned that I could focus on Solutions
I don't have to listen to the naysayers
that they don't make statues of critics
they make statues of the crazy people
the dreamers I could focus like Eric was
saying I could I could set an intention
and spend all my energy looking at that
and screw all the things that weren't
working I learned all this stuff but it
did two things to me it really
fundamentally shifted my life
but secondly I was like damn that gave
Tony money he gave me information it
shifted my life I want to be in that
business so for me it shifted my mindset
but it also shifted my career path and
in 1998 I did my first information
product and then infomercial on TV I
only did an infomercial because there
was no internet back then for those of
you that are a little younger
everybody's like why would you and Tony
have done infomercials because there was
no internet there wasn't even AOL dial
up when I started right so I shared that
with you because it was such a
fundamental shift I account masterminds
workshops Live Events uh I've spent
literally over a million dollars between
hosting them or attending them in my
life and truly I believe it's my unfair
Advantage because
in my 20s I always thought you had to
learn on your own like I have to figure
this out it's got to work harder harder
I know you've heard this before harder
or smarter it's the combo you got to
work smarter and you still got to work
hard
this is insanity that that you're being
told don't monetize your your business
if you have a good business have a good
service have a good product sell it
you know but so many guys are they're
trying these little kid kid gimmicks
you know it's fine if my kids flip shoes
on on on eBay
if you're an adult man you got to get
Beyond flipping
sneakers on ebay
you need to build a business
otherwise don't call yourself an
entrepreneur because that's not what an
entrepreneur an entrepreneur is not
flipping on eBay
that's not a business that's you trying
to make two dollars
on a toy that you bought at a garage
sale it's a different gig now if you can
figure out how to scale that
but it sounds to me like you're you're
benefiting eBay more than you're
benefiting yourself
eBay eBay is the pimp and you're
basically the prostitute in that
Machinery which is no problem with that
right but you're servicing the machine
rather than building your own machine
I want to build a machine
I want to build a machine that lives
longer than I do so that if I get a good
partnership with somebody and we cut a
deal and they're 90 percent of the
profits and future and I'm 10 and my
kids or my charity get to keep that 10
after I'm dead man I'm good to go
so what's next like go the jet like what
what's next man
I don't know what's 10x for you now it's
a Nexus you know how do I do a billion
dollars a year in in income
and then how do I do 10 million in real
estate how do I have a 10 billion real
estate portfolio we paid last month we
paid
uh 1.4 million dollars out in
distribution I'm sorry last month we
paid 1.4 million in US dollars out to
our term investors in the real estate
how do I start competing with these
Banks so they're like you know what we
really don't like all this noise you're
making you're a noisy guy and we're kind
of talk getting tired of it now
when you get noisy enough they either
buy you and suppress you
you know that's what Bill Gates would do
with with apple years ago the tablet the
original iPhone was a little uh called
uh
what was the name of that little beast
um
anyway it had a little pin you wrote on
it they buried that project for years
um I'll think of it in a second I think
of it when the interview is over maybe
you guys know what it is okay anyway
it's probably 20 years ago I actually
had a company built around this thing
and Bill Gates came in gave Apple Steve
Jobs alone and said look I'll lend you
this money
you got to bury that product and they
did
so that's what you can do or they
consume you they buy you and say hey we
want you to be part of our
so maybe maybe that's what happens
Nathan I don't know
I don't know get to get the audio guide
the audio guy to get a good sticker for
the mic
great uncle Leonard's laugh
he smoked cigars for like every year of
my life and I at the time was like 19
and I never saw him without a cigar so
Uncle Leonard smelled like a what
a really old cigar
and everyone knew Uncle Leonard smelled
like a cigar but no one had the courage
to tell Uncle Leonard that he smelled
like a cigar you guys everybody has had
Uncle Leonard somewhere in your life
right because Uncle Leonard was my
grandmother's brother so he had clout
well Jamil was three so he didn't know
he he hasn't been introduced to being
politically correct yet
thank God right so
Jameel was sitting on my uncle Leonard's
lap and we're all talking and Jamil
stops in the middle of a sentence and he
goes
and the first time he sniffed we no big
deal but the second and the third time
then in his little three-year-old voice
Uncle Leonard
you Tink
and you can hear a pin drop in the room
and everyone in that moment was grateful
that they were not jameel's mother
and we all gazed at her bad mom bad mom
the next thing that fell out of Uncle
Leonard's mouth shocked us all
he looked at Jamil with a long gaze
kind of not knowing what's about to
happen gays
and he said
Jamil
I think you're right
I think I think
for the first time in my entire life
Uncle Leonard put out his cigar and the
next time we saw Uncle Leonard it
smelled like he had just been washed for
days
he was always clean but his clothes just
smelled like old cigars and it was very
clear that he got new clothes
see the freedom that a child has
the truth that they stand with think
like a child don't act like a child but
think like a child
be as free as a child see children have
a sense of curiosity children forgive
sooner quicker faster and if you want
something new to come out of your voice
you have to put something new in you in
terms of a commitment my son like I I
would watch the way he would forgive me
and he did something wrong one day and I
have to reprimand him and I immediately
felt guilty and I'm in my office he's
like four years old and I'm on my on my
computer and I'm crying because I'm
single mother guilt entrepreneur
and I'm like and he comes around the
corner he goes mommy and I just
reprimanded him he's on a timeout and
all this stuff and I'm upset I'm crying
he's okay
and he comes around the corner and I'm
and he says Mommy
I was like
yes
do you want to lay down with me
yes
and he goes and he lays off his little
skinny arm and I put my big old head on
that arm
there's something that happens when we
allow ourselves to sit inside Freedom
sit inside
transparency sit inside what I like to
call care frontation
that means I might push up against you a
little bit I might make you mildly to
moderately to significantly
uncomfortable in any form of mediocracy
but it's out of the spirit of love
you want to inspire people with your
voice from your child to your sibling to
your significant other to your community
to the world to this room be willing to
love me enough to tell me your truth
then love me enough to tell me my truth
then love me enough to just tell me the
truth
and and fine
fine
be willing to touch the edge of your own
comfort zone you show me yours and I'll
show you mine
you show me your heart
and I'll show you my love
you let me know that you're willing to
be imperfect and still have a perfectly
giving serving loving life then you give
me permission to let my imperfection out
into the world too
see you want to speak at another level
you got to be willing to love at another
level forgive at another level show up
at another level speak up at another
level pray at another level you have to
be willing on every level to up level
who you be on a daily basis every day of
Our Lives we live in a world that is
incredibly complex and you have to
remember we all have a two million year
old brain
and it's not designed to make you happy
it's designed to make you survive
so it's always looking for what's wrong
so why would we allow this to be because
it's just a bad habit and so we need a
daily practice and so I want to show you
how I do this for me and I want you to
create your own system based on it this
mind serves me I don't negotiate with it
remember I told you I don't say well
I'll do this well maybe we can do it
maybe we'll jump in the water now it's
like it knows I'm not here to negotiate
when I say it we do it
that's what we want to train ourselves
to do today whenever you want to make a
change or improve something
the first place you want to prove it is
in your mental emotional state
if you do something from a pissed off
state from an exhausted state from a
frustrated state from a weak state it
won't matter what you do the thoughts
are weak when you're in a weak place the
actions are weak so the first thing
we're going to do is I'm going to show
you a simple breathing pattern and the
breathing pattern if you're familiar
with yogas like Breath of Fire it's
similar to Breath of Fire and it's a
movement here what it's going to look
like is this you're going to sit up in
your chair with energy we're going to
raise our hands up as we take the air in
and then you're going to blow it out
only going to blow it out your nose and
we're going to do that over and over
again for 30 breaths you're going to do
this with your eyes closed then you're
going to drop your hands down Palms up
on your weight on your legs and you're
just going to feel whatever you feel you
might notice some tingling you might
notice a sense of peace
it might just feel relaxed and then
we'll do another three sets of ten
another thirty we'll relax and then
another so we're gonna do three sets of
30. three sets of ten ten ten ten ten
ten ten ten ten with a break between
them when you're done with that you're
ready to Prime because it puts you in
state priming is three actions it's done
in ten minutes you can do more than ten
and many of you will enjoy it so much
you'll go longer but the reason I do 10
minutes of priming is I wanted to come
up with a daily discipline there was no
excuse not to do if you don't have 10
[ __ ] minutes for your life you don't
have a life so what we're gonna do is
we're gonna do our three sets of ten
three sets of ten three sets of ten then
when their eyes closed the first three
and a third minutes of the ten minutes
is we're going to focus on three
experiences in our life that we can feel
deeply grateful for three of them and
we're not going to think I'm like oh
this this we're gonna take them one at a
time spend about a minute each and step
into that moment in your life that you
could feel grateful for it could be a
little thing or a big thing it doesn't
matter
what matters is that you go there you
know if I ask you what's it like to be
on a roller coaster and you remember
time when you're in a roller coaster and
you picture yourself in a roller coaster
over there
you're going to give me very different
feedback than if I get you to imagine
the moment you were going over the edge
and you're in the front seat
then you're going to show me a different
result you want your gratitude to be in
the front seat not an intellectual
gratitude out there so I take three
minutes
a minute each I come up with something
different every time I think of a moment
that I could feel so grateful for a
blessed moment a beautiful moment a
loving moment a sacred moment and I step
in and feel it and flood myself with the
Gratitude gratitude is the antidote to
the two emotions that mess up most
people's lives what are they anger and
what fear those are the two biggies you
cannot be grateful and angry
simultaneously that's the beauty of it
it's the antidote to anger you can't be
fearful and grateful simultaneously so
the more you cultivate and Prime
yourself for gratitude the more you can
push through anger and fear very quickly
and by the way when I do it
I usually pick two strong ones and then
I pick something really simple and I
make myself really feel the Gratitude
like the wind on my face or the smell of
the ocean if I'm doing it outside by my
house or the look on one of my
children's faces and I'll just fill that
up and the reason is
if all you do is get grateful about big
things you're going to miss most of life
after we do our breathing step one of
the three steps first the breathing then
the three steps one gratitude three
minutes roughly a minute each three
different moments you can feel grateful
for and feel it enjoy it savor it live
in it next three in the third minutes
second piece we're gonna do is you're
gonna feel the energy in you and do a
prayer or a blessing now I know many of
you are not religious I'm not suggesting
you need to be
but almost all of us know there's a
power in love
you know if God was love and we didn't
come up with all the other names for God
you wouldn't have much argument between
people so imagine that what you're going
to do is Imagine uh energy of God the
universe whatever you want to imagine
coming down into you like a white light
and breathing it down in through your
body down your legs into the Earth and
then coming back up and out again so
it's
and then comes back up
and you don't have to do this with your
hands but I'm trying to show you what
the feeling is and while you're doing
this what you're going to do during
those three minutes is you're going to
give thanks it's like a prayer saying
heal my body my mind my emotions
strengthen me make me the best I can be
strengthen my love my passion my courage
whatever it is that you value in
yourself and you feel that happening of
the three minutes I do that for about a
minute and a half and the other minute
half I then take that energy through me
and I send it in a circle around to my
children to my family to my friends to
my co-workers to my associates to my
partners to the people I meet on the
street to my clients and so it's taking
the energy and now you might sound like
woo-woo stuff but the idea of allowing
your nervous system to heal and
strengthen just the focus of that alone
for you is strong and sending to others
as well so you can think it's all
[ __ ] but try it and decide based on
the experience if you do it a while I
think you're going to find it'll deepen
that sense of gratitude because it
becomes not only gratitude but healing
is strengthening and a gift to those you
love the last three minutes I call three
to thrive you're going to think of three
things that you really want to
accomplish or achieve but instead of
like hoping it happens or thinking about
it happening you're going to step in
your mind and experience it as if it's
done you're going to see it or feel it
breathe it celebrate it like you've
already achieved the goal what you're
doing is training your reticular
activating system and we talked about
this the other day the part of your
brain that notices things when you did
you know before you bought that car
outfit you never noticed them now you
buy that car outfit those cars and
outfits are everywhere how come because
your Ras now that your own one says this
is important I need to pay attention to
this well when you get clear what you
want and you see it as done and feel it
and create it in your mind in your heart
and you celebrate it there's a sense of
certainty than there's your body and
your reticular activated system starts
to go to work on making it happen so you
spend a minute each one of those so
basically three minutes each three and
third minutes each and we're done this
is what's so crazy like even as I stand
here like I can't believe I'm in
Columbus Ohio like I can't believe I'm
with Lewis house like I can't believe
I'm with the son with a greatness like
guys I was out I I was just homeless
like I was just literally sleeping in
abandoned buildings I was literally just
thinking about committing suicide right
and so so what happened was I was
introduced I was probably about 16
almost 17 and I was introduced to a
pastor a friend of mine took me to
church with him and it was the oddest
thing I went to church maybe about three
or four times and I didn't grow up in
church so I wasn't really there for like
the religious aspect of it but this was
my best friend and this is where he went
regularly right and and I loved it it
kind of reminds me of this Summit you
know it was a lot of positive people
right first time in my life being an
environment with just positivity right
they would sing and the pastor would
speak and we'd have a dinner after every
church I think that's probably why I
went because it was like a meal really
you know I'm saying when you homeless
and your high school dropout you ain't
got a trash can like a hot meal is just
unbelievable right that's why I'm gonna
fool you to this day right and so but
I'll never forget he would say to me you
know maybe maybe three or four weeks
into going regularly you know he said to
me kid what are you doing with your life
and I'm like what does that mean exactly
he's like what's your goals what's your
dreams like I don't have any goals any
dreams like my biological father wasn't
in my life my mom got pregnant with me
at 17 years old like I don't come from
what you know what what we call like the
Ola meals experience you know I'm not
like you know my great-grandfather a
picture with my grandfather and then my
father and me like I don't I don't know
what I want to do and I remember maybe
about the second month of coming to
church he would say to me he'd say you
know what you need to get your GED and
you need to go to college
and I was like what
like don't you know I'm living like I'm
living in abandoned buildings like I'm
working at McDonald's and I'm eating
McDonald's like I like my mother is 7 17
when she had me she didn't finish height
well she barely finished high school she
didn't go to college my Grandma had 14
kids none of them went to college like
we don't do college
you know and it was just so weird this
is why you need to be in this type of
environment because this environment
activates and give you permission to do
I'm sorry I get excited because I'm not
supposed to be on the stage listen to me
I was literally homeless I was coming to
church not really taking showers I
wasn't brushing my teeth and this guy
looked at me and said you need to get
your GED you need to leave Detroit I'm
going to send you to college because
greatness is upon you
guys that that's why this environment is
so important because what he did was he
allowed me to see who I was before I
could really see who I was
and he saw guys I just we just buried
him about four weeks ago and and he saw
something in me like like everybody in
the world now says like yo E.T I watch
your video and this happened and I have
and E.T you know I get inspired I was 16
17 years old I had never spoken a day in
my life and this guy saw it like he saw
something to me that I didn't see and he
gave me permission to be where other
people said I couldn't be he gave me
permission to believe I was great he
gave me permission to think I could
change the world he gave me permission
to start something that had never
started in my family before he gave me
permission to say I am I am I am
he gave me permission to say I am
brilliant
uh yeah I might be different but I am
brilliant yep I might be loud but I am
special
he gave me permission and so the first
thing I want you to do today is I want
you to keep saying to yourself I am I am
I am I am and for those of you who
hadn't quite started yet I am and for
those of you who gotten started I am why
because I can't believe that I started
with a GED and that GED turned into a
four-year degree took me 12 years guys
it took me 12 years but Pastor would
keep telling me you are brilliant you
are special Eric yes you're different
and yes you're not doing it to
traditional route but greatness is upon
you you got to keep going you got to
keep going you got to keep going in the
12 years to get the four-year degree
turn into a master's degree
and the Master's Degree turned into a
PhD God I can't believe it
I went from being a High School Dropout
from being homeless living in abandoned
buildings to eating out of trash cans to
Dr Eric Thomas to writing six books guys
are you hearing what I'm saying today
stop playing small and start playing big
because
the Widow pushed past failure is to keep
making progress part of the reasons why
you stick on failure and feeling so bad
about yourself and it's never going to
work out because there's nothing new
that you're working on that's exciting
that you're building towards that you
feel like you're making progress on
because when you're making progress and
you're moving forward you can't feel
like a failure and you don't have time
to think about the failures that you've
had
people ask me all the time hey what do
you do when one of your videos fail
it might be
the analytics and show hey when this
happened your video tank yes and we do
that and we learn from it but I don't
have time to sit there and look at
all of just the failures and sit on it
because I've got more videos that I need
to make another video is coming out
tomorrow and another videos come out the
next day another videos come out the
next day and I don't know how many
videos we put out every day across all
of our channels but it's a lot of
content and I'm so focused on the next
thing that I'm less focused on the one
that was so learn from that awesome now
move forward and when you don't have
anything that you're moving forward
towards that's when it starts to really
hit hard and so that's
I think that's really important I think
we get too caught up on our first one
and it being amazing and nobody liking
it and so we're gonna stop and and even
for me my first video I figured how many
months it was between my first video of
all time and then my second video but
but it was a while before I kept going
because the first video didn't do as
well as I thought I I would do uh I
wasn't as good as I thought it was gonna
be I was way more nervous than I thought
it was going to be and I got no comments
right like my mom and my sister
commented on my video and I felt like a
failure so I stopped going
and the thing that saved me the most
over however many years of making videos
the decade plus has been you keep going
you keep making content you keep
creating you put it in your calendar and
you keep doing something to build
momentum towards a dream that you want
and so I think that's incredibly
valuable whether you're going through a
big failure or a mini failure I think it
helps when I look at big failures in my
life right so a video failing that's a
small failure right like this if this
video doesn't go and blow up it's a
small failure but big failures the two
biggest ones was one personal and one
business the business one is my in my
first company we I quit I'm a business
partner I just I felt like a loser I was
not making money writing making 300
bucks a month having no results no
traction I just feel like a total
failure and nothing was working out and
I told my business partner that I quit
and the thing that got me through it was
eventually just realizing hey somebody
else has done this
I can model success and I looked at Bill
Gates and how he started Microsoft and I
learned from that and built my company
but it was the the progress that moving
forward instead of being stuck on how
everything sucks and I suck and I'm not
getting results and I'm just failing the
thing that got me the energy to keep
going was
feeling like this progress towards a new
idea or a new strategy to help me
accomplish my goals my biggest personal
failure was getting divorced over 10
years ago and that was that was really
rough you know it was a personal it felt
like a personal failure I mean it ended
up being the best thing for both of us
but at the time it felt like a huge
failure even just
saying that I you know am divorced
um
it just felt like a giant failure that I
suck as a human that that I couldn't
make this work and
that took a while to get through and
eventually the thing that
that helped me was
I pulled up a dating app and I saw uh
options you know I was like oh you know
what okay this could maybe maybe this
could work or or that could work and
it's like
idea of progress
towards something instead of being stuck
in the past is the thing that started to
get me through the build some momentum
understand that if you're living in
Failure right now it's it's just the
past you're living in the past you're
you're frustrated with what what
happened and what you should have done
differently and could have done
differently and you wish you said this
or did that or acted a certain way
you're just constantly repeating the
past where to get out of the past to get
out of the failure now we need to think
present and future what are we working
towards what are we building towards
what are we creating and making and as
soon as you can shift from past to
present or future that starts to allow
your your brain to shift into forward
momentum and progress instead of living
in Failure so some of the steps that you
you can do that I think can help one
put activity into your calendar
so whatever you're working towards if it
didn't work out once awesome put in your
calendar to keep going
today is a Tuesday as I'm filming this
video Tuesday is my video day I'm I'm
making content on Tuesday
you know we're here and we're sitting in
the parking lot my my wife Nina is
running some errands doing shipping out
some built to serve books I believe
right now here at the shipping center
and I'm making content because it's in
my calendar if I didn't have content day
and it wasn't scheduled in I wouldn't be
making content I'd be doing something
else or I might be thinking about all
the past failures that I had in my
content
but because it's a scheduled in my
calendar I'm making progress moving
forward so whatever you want to make
progress and move forward towards have
chunks of time in your calendar
dedicated to doing it two have something
that inspires you it could be people it
could be remembering what impact you're
trying to have your big mission or your
vision you're trying to accomplish one
of the things that really helped me
early in my career is I made a
PowerPoint file of all the people who
came to my events my my seminars my
speaking gigs and
the message that they had for me they
wrote to me because I feel great the
next day after an event but then I would
I would lose the vibe but lose the
momentum that didn't feel like who cares
it doesn't matter anymore but I would I
would watch his PowerPoint file where I
put their quotes and how much of an
impact that was having on them and so it
reminded me of why I do what I do and
gave me more energy momentum to keep
moving forward that becomes critical
like what inspires you to want to move
forward maybe it's watching videos like
this maybe it's looking at testimonials
from the people who who you've helped
maybe it's remembering your big goal and
dream of what you're trying to
accomplish but what inspires you to want
to start building some momentum and then
three model success and find the people
who are doing the thing or have done the
thing that you're trying to do and learn
from them and study them and what that
does is it gives you
hope and strategies
when you are studying people who've done
the thing that you want to do it gives
you the hope that it's possible for you
too right because when you look at their
story they probably started with less
than what you have right now and in
studying them you can see oh if they
could do it maybe I can too it's just
that hope because you don't see anybody
in your family your friend's Circle
doing what you want to do and so it
feels impossible but when you're around
the people who are doing it even just by
reading their book or watching their
videos it gives you the hope that it's
possible and then two it gives you the
strategy of what you could be doing so
how do you go from where you are now to
where you want to be well if you're
modeling success and you see what they
did it gives you hope plus the strategy
to actually go off and execute so coming
back to the theme of failure what this
video is all about you're gonna have
tons of failure it's gonna happen like
if you are not failing it means you're
not taking a big enough shot right if
you're not failing you're just doing
things that you know how to do
therefore you're just in your comfort
zone therefore you just hate your life
right if you're not if you have zero
failure happening in your life then
you're taking zero chances and you're
just doing what you know how to do and
you'll be bored and you won't like your
life so recognize that failure is a part
of the process and as soon as we can
move from past I suck as a human I made
all these mistakes too okay I'm moving
forward we're making progress we got a
big thing that we're chasing down when
you can move from failure to progress it
gives you the momentum it gives you the
hope it gives you the energy and ends up
giving you a lot better results as well
one of my favorite studies about
exercise and they had three cohorts in
this study so they have first cohort
they said I just want you to track how
often you work out over the next few
weeks right so that's the the standard
cohort the control group second group is
that we want to track off new exercise
but we're also going to give you a
motivation motivational speech
presentation talk about the benefits of
heart health why habits are good for you
and so on so this is the motivated group
right the third group they got the same
presentation so they're equally
motivated and then they did one thing
differently and that one thing was they
filled out this sentence is that during
the next week I will partake in at least
20 minutes of vigorous exercise on this
day in this at this time in this place
right they specifically stated their
intention to implement the behavior so
implementation and tension here's what
happened
first group one out of three of them
worked out second group motivation did
nothing as soon as they left the
researchers facility the next day they
weren't motivated it's like reading a
book or watching a YouTube or listening
to a motivational speaker and then you
forget all about it 20 minutes later
um
but the third group the group that has
specific plan for how they were going to
implement the behavior nine out of 10 of
them worked out so you can increase your
odds of success two to three x just by
having a specific plan and this is the
Insight many people think that they lack
motivation when what they really lack is
clarity they think that they need to get
more motivated that they need willpower
in order to execute on a habit if I just
felt like writing if I just felt like
meditating I felt like working out then
I would do it but in fact they don't
have a plan for it so they wake up each
day thinking I wonder if I'll feel
motivated to write today I wonder if
I'll feel motivated to work out today
but instead you can take the decision
making out of it by explicitly stating
when where and how you will implement
the Habit it sounds easy to say let's
just start a plan let's you know write
down exactly what you should do and then
maybe you'll follow through on it but of
course we all know that there are
challenges that arise it's not quite
that easy so here's a little strategy
that I like to use to make sure you can
come up with a better plan of action and
it's called a failure pre-mortem so the
way that it works is you think about the
Habit the project the goal whatever the
most important thing is that you want to
work on and I want you to imagine fast
forward six months from now and you
failed and then tell the story of why
you failed what happened what challenges
did you encounter what was it that took
you off course
um when I do this with businesses
sometimes we call it the kill the
company exercise because everybody just
sits around thinks about ways to kill
the company in the next six months and
once you have all that stuff laid out on
the table in front of you you can start
to make better choices about how to
develop a plan you can start to have if
then plans so not only do I want to
exercise for 20 minutes on Monday at 5
PM but also if I do not exercise because
I have to take my kid to practice or
whatever then it's Tuesday morning at
7am I will go in right you can have ways
to adjust for these challenges and one
of the things that will help you to do
the work to create the things that you
want in your life is it will help you if
you train your mind
to start spotting evidence as you're
doing the work as you're going through
your day it will help you if you train
your mind to start scanning the world
and spotting evidence that yes indeed
the world is sending you positive
signals that things are going to work
out now why is it important to train
your mind to help you get what you want
well the reason why is because if you
get into a negative mindset if you start
thinking
this business is never going to work why
even bother I'm never going to meet
anybody it's nothing but losers out
there look at all these idiots on hinge
why the hell should I keep doing this if
you allow your mind to start to rest in
a pessimistic negative protective scared
and doubtful stance your mind will
continue to show you reasons why there's
nobody on hinged worth talking to your
mind will continue to show you all the
reasons why you will never make it in
business your mind will continue to show
you all the reasons why you're never
going to lose that weight and be able to
tuck in your shirt as my friend Corinne
Crabtree always talks about that
transformational moment and when your
mind goes negative your mind starts to
scan the world and will show you more
reasons to stop and the power of
training your mind to spot positive
signs is very simple the power is that
your mind will start to show you reasons
to keep going your mind will help you
take the step your mind will encourage
you to feel optimistic to feel empowered
just like you woke up today on a Tuesday
and it was February 22nd 2022 and those
numbers are lining up and that makes you
in your heart and soul go whoa something
cool could happen today like that [ __ ]
only happens like once in my lifetime
those numbers are going to line up like
that today is a really cool day let's go
do something with this you could create
that kind of attitude every single
freaking day of your life you could if
you train your mind and if you start
taking action and training your mind is
the key piece that we're going to talk
about so for those of you that have read
the high five habit one of the things
that I talk about a lot is every single
day find a naturally occurring
heart-shaped object in the world it
could be a stone it could be a leaf it
could be a cloud it could be a shape in
your coffee hey Chris if we've got
anything around here that looks like a
heart hand it to me and the reason why I
love telling you to start playing a game
with yourself well you start your day
going mind brain show me some heart oh
what is this come here dog treat oh my
God it's a dog treat look at this guys
what shape is that
that right there is a harp
there we go check that out if you say
brain mind show me a heart today guess
what's gonna happen that damn dog
biscuit it's gonna show it's gonna
you're gonna be like there's a heart
you're gonna look out at the sky and
you're gonna see a heart shape oh right
there in the mountains there's a heart
shape in the mountains in southern
Vermont you're going to see it in the
clouds what you're doing when you tell
your mind what's important to you is
you're telling your mind and the filter
in your brain to change in real time and
allow into your consciousness
what's important to you and if you want
to see hearts by God those damn dog
treats are going to start looking like
hearts everybody that's how you train
your mind it's freaking incredible and
if you want to see evidence of this
follow me on social media if you follow
me Mel Robbins on social media you will
see every day I am reposting your
stories of finding heart shapes around
the world now why is this important well
it's important because it's a simple way
to prove to you that your mind changes
in real time that if you get serious
about becoming more positive and
optimistic and encouraging of yourself
if you get serious about saying this I
don't want to see all the reasons why
I'm unhappy I don't want to see
everybody else in the world that's
launched a business or that's lost
weight and is healthy or that has a
really good marriage or relationship and
I don't want to see that and and have my
mind process it as evidence that it's
never going gonna happen for me I want
my mind to reprogram itself and see
other people's businesses and see other
people getting healthy and see other
people in relationships and I want my
mind to say yeah if they can do it I can
do it that's evidence if that person can
get healthy so can I if that person can
find somebody on hinge so can I if that
person can reconcile with their child so
can I other people can become evidence
that you can have it too right now your
mind is so [ __ ] up from your past that
when you see what other people have and
you don't have it you can't actually
translate it through a negative mind and
and see that that's evidence that you're
going to win you see it like oh somebody
already stole what I wanted that sucks
and so what I want to start to open your
mind to is that you have the power to
train your mind
to filter the world differently just
like you woke up and you saw the date
today 2 22 22 and your brain saw that
was like whoa this is a once in a
lifetime day everybody
you're never going to have another day
that lines up like this ever
what are you gonna do with this day your
mind already interpreted this as wow
something cool could happen
and if you tell yourself something
amazing is going to happen today
something will because you're going to
be looking for it I swear to God
something will something will if you
want to see the good all around you you
got to tell your mind you want to see
the good and this just isn't a bunch of
horsesh everybody this isn't toxic
positivity there is a filter in your
brain called the reticular activating
system
the reticular activating system I call
it the RAS I like to think about it like
a giant hair net on your head and this
Ras sits over your brain I'm probably
getting this wrong I'm not a
neuroscientist I could give about
getting it right I just need you to know
the basics here so that you can apply it
to your life okay you don't need a PhD
to use the science that super smart
people have been working really hard on
in order to apply it to your life that's
what I'm here for in your life I'm here
to translate this stuff into simple
believable and actionable things that
you can do to take all this super cool
stuff that people are researching and
apply it to your normal person's
everyday life to help you change from
the inside out and one of the coolest
things that you have at your disposal is
you have a whole system in your body
that you can train and change and one of
those things that you can train and
change that is impacted by that real
that word you're hearing a lot of
neuroplasticity that just means that
things are able to twist and bend and
change and you're able to learn new
things for as long as you're alive as
long as you're breathing everybody you
got a chance to change the way that you
think as long as you are breathing you
got a chance to change from the inside
out how you experience your life as long
as you are still here watching me people
you got a chance to create a new
experience in your life and one of the
things that helps a lot is understanding
that right now all of the bullsh from
your past has jammed the filter in your
mind body and spirit the reticular
activating system and it is clouding
your ability to look at the world around
you and see hearts remember this dog
treat hearts look at that there's a
heart right there
because you made it this far in a video
I want to celebrate you most people
start and don't finish most people never
actually follow through most people say
they want something but they don't ever
do the work to actually get it but
you're different you are special believe
Nation you made it here all the way to
the end and I love you so it's a special
celebration if you put a hashtag believe
down in the comments Below on this video
I will showcase you and celebrate you
somewhere on the screen in a future
video because you are awesome to learn
the 10 habits that successful people run
daily check the video right there next
to me I think you'll love it continue to
believe and I'll see you there
priorities mean two things cannot be
equally important when you work on
something if I spend 30 minutes on both
things and I say this one's more
important than this one I can say that
but that's not reality